thank the faith the renown about it
hey Larry
hello Larry
what are you doing
look I'm just cleaning out some of this
junk are you going someplace yeah yeah I
have to take a couple of days off sort
of rest up a bit
well why what's the trouble oh I saw dr.
Trott he says I've got a little one
o'clock there's nothing serious is that
it's just
I've got TV
No
well it's a good thing you found out in
time
what did Clark recommend he wants me to
go to bed I'm gonna stay home for a
while let mom take care Mary what did
dr. Clark say what do you mean
he wants me to go to a sanatorium I'm
gonna stay home that's all there is to
it you know that it there's more to it
than that
we didn't back the campaign to have
everyone in Plainville x-ray just so
that our Star reporter could make
monkeys out of us look at that story how
would it look if the man who wrote that
story didn't take his own advice fool
Larry and dr. Carr think you want to go
to a sanatorium you're going to go even
if I have to not get out and carry you
there
you're not funny mister not funny at all
I got on my way you can't walk out like
this decide you want however joining us
for dinner
as a matter of fact Ellen's there
already
I've gotta tell her
I'm sorry about blowing off like that
you know
you go and break the news to Helen when
Carol gets here we'll come in and rest
oh darling I thought you'd never get
here what's the matter Larry I I've got
some bad news Alan you better sit down
oh no what happened did Phil fire you I
hope he did it no we can get married
right away no no I didn't fire me
exactly just I'm played we can't get
nice
don't get mad that is not right away
Oh Larry what is it what's wrong have I
done anymore no no one isn't here it's
me
I've got the per kilo sir
moment I thought you didn't love me
anymore when you go away go away I have
to go anywhere just going home and go to
bed sanitarium I thought you had to go
to one Sakura tuberculosis you sound as
though you wanted me to come it's not at
least you owe Larry all I want is for
you to get well just as soon as you can
hello in there and we come in we'll work
this thing out
don't you worry heaven you can count on
me Phil hello Larry
don't tell me the news but don't worry
everything's going to turn out alright
just as it did for us are you what
didn't tell you know Carol I haven't
told them yet sit down
you see Larry I had TV myself but cured
at the same sanatorium dr. Clark once
you deliver was pretty tough a lot
tougher than it should have been and all
because I didn't think the doctors knew
what they were talking about what do you
do what they told me to do when I first
discovered that I had TB I was terribly
Worth Carol and I were already married
was tough but my doctor said the
sanatorium RL so I went anyway I began
to see everything went fine for a while
then I began to worry again
that's digiti finally I got something
left
walk out without the doctors okay what
happened then what usually happens he
had a relaxed they carried him back to
the sanatorium and it took that
experience to set me wise to myself from
then on everything was fine
oh it was slow but there was progress
not just as far as my health was
concerned it was progress up here too
I have time to think and write it's
because of those stories I wrote in bed
that I have this office here today I
really believe that the three years I
spent in the sanatorium three years
three years flat on my back in a
sanatorium I want to get married
you can't expect a girl away three years
a man who years if it takes that long
darling I love you right I wish you
could go to the sanatorium today so you
could start getting better right away
and anyway now you didn't get the point
bill needed three years because he had a
relapse
if he hadn't left without the doctor's
permission it wouldn't have happened
like you can't wait to get me into that
hasta well that's not good I can't
afford I've got a mother to support she
couldn't get along with that she's
alright but you get along without you
permanently
you were
no it'll win
well today's the day they'll be in the
sanatorium in an hour
how do you feel okay I guess little
scared
it's always the first plunge that's bad
this time tomorrow you'll be an old hand
they're a great bunch out there
especially dr. Martin you'll like them
let's get going
the nice looking place builder
maybe you see the view from the room
registration rooms right down the
corridor so quiet here where is
everybody
now this is the rest period yeah here we
are
fine mr. Specter we haven't seen you in
a long time miss Butler is nice to see
Mary I want you to meet the gal who
saved my life a dozen times all she has
to do is smile and you feel better this
is Larry Scott how do you do this guy's
well he's my best reporter I want you to
take good care of it we've been
expecting you missus - your records
thank you dr. cox's noise so you checked
through this form and it's all the
information is correct
a little worried about and
mental outlook we were then worried
about human
right
and then I'll drop in and see da c'mon
goodbye miss then I'll come up with your
settle Larry you're later Phil and now
if you'll come with me we'll get to
settle in your room
come in hey miss Butler that's right
okay this is Larry Scott a new patient
that's the biscuit hey Larry slaw you
could put your street clothes on I tear
them it's it's toffee
there's small things in the night table
here I'll be back later to see how
you're getting on
there goes nothing
a little man
yeah nah come on I'll be along directly
yes
anything I can do please no
you
all right I guess I better be going
take it easy Larry do what they tell you
to and relax that relax I'll see you in
a couple of weeks
but
so your name is Larry Scott - Scott
diamond phone died no kid of yours I
suppose never been before night
that's nice time paste your telephone
line on that
ever been to a sanatorium before
some guys here I've been back two and
three times they never learned
start living high as soon as we get out
first thing you know bang relapsed back
they come
stupid ain't it yeah here I talk to this
boat over gosh you'll get over that
you'll feel better once you learn how to
rely
good morning it's a beautiful day
I just tied of your leg you take a nap
or light
is anything worrying you Scott good
afternoon Larry here's that book the one
but nine unforeseen
at the rest
learn how to rest
and relax
relax and relax relax and relax a really
nice time for babies and relax relax
but disturb house thought let's bother
you but we had everything straightened
out no doctor sleep I've never good
night a since I got here better go home
I told you I didn't think I could make a
go of it home you're worrying about
postal worker has told you that
everything is going smoothly they're
staying relaxed kuszak touch any but
sleep here you know Larry relaxation is
really a state of mind your state of
mind
well I'll see that you sleep tonight
light sedative will do the trick
tomorrow morning if you still want to
we'll talk about your leaving good night
Larry
what are you doing cut
Marty lie
and talking about you
congratulation we're going to be married
today
Oh today I said I'd wait 30 years Larry
stop
I'm sorry missus cop is intense he's
gone to a funeral food you know fire
down here oh of course
Oh
terror that dream jealous if I burn a
fight but fighting all the wrong thing
running everything
stuff tuberculosis dead myself
I'm out learn how to rest
well how do you feel this morning I feel
fine
you sure they make you sleep through
breakfast I'm hungry - I could eat
something I'll see if I can find
something Tiffin tomato juice on your
table
now your program for the time being is
complete bed rest remember Larry you're
here the rest that means conserving your
energy in every way you can I'll try
turn over or move around only enough to
keep from getting cramped you can sit up
to eat or to read occasionally
good
still want to talk about going home no
doctor I am I'm beginning to feel a
little better about the whole thing
hello there hey how are you hello they
look glad you could make it
you're looking fine feel fine they fell
I want you to meet the customers that's
telephone lines when I start out this is
my boss still factor X line hello
mathematics
yeah our Carol of happy and if you seen
Helen might be and the social worker
tilt away in a minute one thing at a
time
your mother's fine the house for dinner
that Joan this is mr. Baxter those
animals I've been making her for his
little girl of course they'll be
sterilized before past together
hello mr. Baxter I've been hearing about
your little girl for some time now that
you like a pill showing that camel John
I think that's the best one I remember
Patsy always liked to camel festive to
sue well Larry we consume let you get
out of bed a little each day your x-rays
of ensuring steady improvement and you
consume in real progress I get there
we're up to two hours a day of out of
that activity mr. Scott Oh incidentally
the latest issue of the sanatorium
newspaper was really tough but in
addition to editing sidelights what do
you think of a plan to start a class in
short story writing with you with
instructors I like that I'd be very glad
to do it
goodbye me Scott take care of yourself
Tobias thank you for everything
hello I've waited so long for this day
here about ready I have to see dr.
Martin first come on I want you to meet
I'm deeply grateful for all you've done
for me
I hope I can do something for you
something take care of yourself Larry
remember that you have a new kind of
life to live and everything will be
alright see dr. Clark he's expected
he'll work out a complete set of
instructions be assured of all of them
I'll remember and I'll do just that
goodbye Larry thanks again for
everything goodbye goodbye dr. Martin
I like that dr. Martin Barry what did he
mean about your having to live a new
kind of life well a TB patient has to
watch himself pretty carefully get
enough rest good food and dress warmly
and of course he is doctor regularly
that's what everyone should do a little
bit
the TVR has to go
hi there greetings from the news
supervisor of the Thorndike telephone
company I made it
Gus good old Gus turf it I knew
hello
very I wonder if you can come out here
today and be my fliers exhibit with a
new patient young engineer he's a very
sick man and he stopped her to handle a
new word I thought if he heard your
story
hold everything doctor I'm on my way
with people like Larry on the team we
can beat TV